what's up
have you ever wondered why winter is
cold and flu season science offers
several possible reasons one winter days
are shorter with less exposure to
sunlight people's bodies make less
vitamin D which the immune system needs
to fight off disease two people tend to
spend more time inside where airborne
germs spread more easily three Winter's
dry air helps preserve the viruses that
cause the flu and covid-19 it also helps
them hang out in the air for longer
increasing the chance that someone will
breathe them in plus dry air May harm
the cells lining our Airways and slow
the movement of germulated mucus out of
our bodies four cold air makes it harder
for our bodies to produce Tiny Bubbles
called extracellular vesicles those
bubbles can lure viruses away from cells
and kill them with fewer of the bubbles
around viruses are more likely to attack
cells
so in addition to face masks humidifiers
and house exhaust fans might help board
off wintertime illnesses